un sujet emmanuel macron n'a pas laissé
de place au doute
hier devant les maires il s'est
formellement prononcé contre
l'interdiction des listes communautaires
aux élections municipales
et voilà qu'il n'a pas plu à bruno
retailleau qui est à l'initiative de
cette proposition grave il s'exprimait
ce matin sur public sénat emmanuel
macron je l'accuse de refuser le combat
contre l'islamisme qui n'est pas une
religion qui est une idéologie politique
qui s'appuie sur le dévoiement d'une
religion est aujourd'hui évidemment je
prétends pas tout résoudre mais la
république française est soumise à un
choix est-ce que nous engageons le
combat avec toutes les armes des armes
républicaines qui sont à notre portée ou
est-ce que nous démissionnons mails
macron propose la démission et de la
démission à la soumission
il n'y a qu'un pas alors je vous pose la
question vous mihaely né ce que vous
trouvez que macron à démissionner le
problème c'est que je vois pas comment
on pourrait exactement définir que ce
que c'est con liste
comme guitariste et qu'il n'est pas
parce que c'est pas certain idées ne
sont pas interdites donc autant je pense
que red bull retailleau a raison qu'il
faut se battre que ces temps il y en un
véritable problème politique exactement
autant source sur cette question précise
je vois pas comment on peut le faire
concrètement
c'est à dire qu'elle va être contenu de
la loi quels gens des personnes vont
être interdits sachant que par exemple
cinéma on élus se couvrent la tête par
exemple l'assemblée nationale c'est le
règlement intérieur de notre
assimilation qui veulent interdire de
siéger avec avec un couvre chef
du coup religieusement ostentatoire à
mon avis ça pourrait être ça va être
partout où siègent des élus donc je vois
pas en quoi ces combats là est utile
pour servir une cause que je soutiens à
100%
claire chartier votre avis sur la
question moi j'ai toujours une certaine
méfiance face à ce genre de tentation de
réponse aux brandir larmes de
l'interdiction pour évacuer un problème
ça me paraît un peu une forme de
simplisme voire d' autoritarisme
idéologie qui est pas très productif et
en effet on peut quand même considérer
qu'on est pas loin du rétablissement de
délits d'opinion parce que
en démocratie et dans notre démocratie
républicaine bah on a le droit de
défendre publiquement des idées si on va
par là et si on commence à se dire qu'on
va interdire ça on va faire exactement
le jeu des islamistes parce que c'est
exactement ce qu'ils cherchent et
d'ailleurs c'est ce que mettait
d'ailleurs dans ses brochures affaiblir
les fondements même des démocraties les
faire vaciller sur leur socle
donc cela me semble extrêmement
dangereux ensuite bon la laïcité ça
n'interdit pas de défendre publiquement
ses idées et un parti politique un parti
politique c'est une association de
citoyens qui sont regroupés autour d'une
philosophie commune
donc c'est une organisation qui défend
une certaine vision donc je vois pas ça
on ne peut pas ça n'arrive ce n'est pas
une émanation de l'état donc elle est
mêlée en plus la question de la laïcité
la dent me semble alors là extrêmement
périlleux parce que l'état la laïcité ça
ce qu'est ce que ça signifie c'est que
l'état et garde sa neutralité ne peut
pas se prononcer pour ou contre une
religion sans faille donne la liberté de
penser et de croire donc ça me semble
très typique de cette
instrumentalisation de la laïcité de
sète qui devient mais vraiment le plus
grand mot valise de la société française
on y met absolument ce qu'on il veut sur
le fond évidemment qu'il faut lutter jeu
on est tous d'accord factiva dire il
faut pas réagi dernier point je trouve
que c'est quand même un problème parce
que les mêmes qui disent on doit avoir
le droit de critiquer une religion
en l'espèce l'islam en revanche ils
dénient cette liberté de penser à
d'autres qui veulent effectivement
promouvoir certaines idées donc la
limite à trouver c'est de voir
effectivement si concrètement au niveau
municipal puisque ce sont des listes
pour les élections municipales et bien
ses ministres dans la municipalité de
décider ce qui va être accepté ce qui va
pas être acceptées mais vraiment je
pense qu'en l'état
c'est extrêmement périlleux commun alors
sur la laïcité avant de vous donner la
parole alexis poulain arnaud benedetti
je voudrais juste qu'on réécoute les
propos du chef de l'état sur le
communautarisme c'était justement hier
devant les maires bien entendu rester
silencieux sur la question du
communautarisme de l'islamisme politique
temps évoqué ces dernières semaines et
ces derniers mois dans notre pays je ne
veux rien cacher ici de la réalité que
beaucoup d'entre vous vivent dans
certaines communes dans certains
quartiers progresse depuis quelques
années un projet de séparation d'avec la
république
c'est une réalité alors c'est une
réalité dit le président de la
république mais il n'empêche alexis
poulain on a du mal à comprendre la
vision des manuels marron sur ce sujet
là images à l'écran il est président de
la république est garant des lois et des
institutions
on a des lois bien fait on a une
constitution bien fait ce que fait
monsieur retailleau c'est du
clientélisme politique c'est à dire
qu'il fait croire que les lois sont mal
faites et que une liste commune
intéristes pourraient se présenter avec
des valeurs contraires à celles de la
république c'est impossible
les lois sont faites de telle façon que
c'est impossible donc il est simplement
là en train de faire un rappel à la loi
maison que c'est un débat inutile il a
raison maintenant ce qu'on aimerait
c'est qu'il fasse la même chose avec
infirmation sur ce qu'est la laïcité
républicaine parce que la laïcité
française est une exception culturelle
encore mieux dans d'autres pays elles
s'organisent autrement en france c'est
l'état qui organise laïcité justement
pour que chacun soit libre de penser de
croire ce qu'il veut et qu'il n'y ait
pas justement ce set cette foire
d'empoigné qu'on est en train de voir
simplement parce que les gens sont
complètement confus dans leur tête et ne
comprennent pas cette fois bien fait
encore une fois une loi bien fait et
donc il est dans son rôle de président
il a tout à fait raison de dire qu'il
n'ya aucune raison d'interdire des
listes communautariste puisque si jamais
elle venait à exister et être anti
républicaine elle serait dé facto hors
la loi arnaud mine ity vous êtes
d'accord il et clientéliste bruno
retailleau
je ne sais pas si les clientélismes à ce
que je vois surtout dans les propos du
président de la république c'est aussi
une pierre jetée dans le jardin du sénat
clairement
aussi il faut voir le contexte dans
lequel il s'exprime et il s'est exprimé
devant l'assemblée des maires et
d'ailleurs il a tenu un discours d'une
heure vingt et on a retenu finalement de
son expression uniquement le fait qu'il
s'opposait à ce que l'on légifère sur
l'interdiction des listes
communautariste ceci dit moi je maudirai
un peu quand même les propos que je
viens d'entendre autour de cette table
je pense quand même qu'il ne faut pas
non plus aveugle et sur le combat qui
est mené par un certain nombre de
prosélytes dans ce pays parce que ils
s'attaquent fondamentalement quand même
aux fondements de la république
le problème c'est qu'ils remettent en
distinguant il remettre en question
quand même quelque chose qui est
essentiel dans la l'organisation de la
cité qui est l'organisation de la cité
républicaine c'est la distinction entre
le temporel et le spirituel c'est
d'ailleurs le coeur même de la charia
que de remettre en cause cette
distinction c'est il ya là un verrou
d'ailleurs théologique qui pose la
question
aussi il ne faut pas se voiler la face
si je puis dire son mauvais jeu de mots
sur la question de l'articulation de
l'islam en général à la république qui
est un système politique qui fait cette
distinction clairement entre le
spirituel et le temporel et c'est pour
ça que nous avons autant de difficultés
aujourd'hui à faire en sorte d'
acculturés politiquement l'islam à la
république à un système qui fonctionne
sur cette distinction nous avons eu des
difficultés avec le christianisme
également mais sauf que le christianisme
avait une facilité théologique qui
permettait quand même de faire cette
distinction que le spirituel et temporel
et on peut pas nier cette réalité c'est
une réalité de fait à laquelle
aujourd'hui nous sommes confrontés nous
regardent au delà de ça en effet ce
n'est pas une interdiction qui va
vraiment régler le problème aujourd'hui
de l'expression politique constitue lise
la mise sauf qu'avec emmanuel macron on
a un problème si vous voulez fondamental
c'est que ils dénoncent ils dénoncent le
communautarisme
il dénonce le sécessionnisme il ne cesse
de le faire depuis quelques mois mais le
pire c'est qu'il n'agit pas le problème
c'est qu'il n'agit pas le problème c'est
qu'il n'agit pas et toute une partie de
l'opinion publique française aujourd'hui
qui s'est considérablement durcie quant
à cette question là tant sur des actes
et non pas sur des discours on nous
promet un discours sur la laïcité depuis
des mois et des mois on ne voit rien
venir
en outre au mais un certain nombre de
mesures on ne voit rien venir
la difficulté aujourd'hui d' emmanuel
macron c'est que elle il y aussi à sa
majorité même à sa majorité politique à
la façon dont il a construit son
appareil politique et j'allais dire
presque sa doxa politique c'est à dire
qu'on ne peut pas être en même temps en
même temps sur cette question dans tous
les camps et si vous voulez autant il
arrive sur des questions économiques sur
des questions sociales à avoir au niveau
de sa majorité
une forme d'unité autant sur cette
question qui est une question
essentielle qui est une question qui
divise qui clivent profondément la
société française il n'arrive pas à
avoir une martingale qui lui permet
justement de produire en tout cas une
vision claire et surtout une action
claire de ce qu'il faut faire pour
lutter contre les contres les prosélytes
que sont les islamistes y n'y a ni
perdant votre avis sur la question
je pense
la question de ce qu'il pense vraiment
et fondamentales et à mon avis à mon
avis emmanuel macron tu crois qu'en fait
il n'y a pas de problème que tout est
soluble dans des plus derrière plus de
formations moins de chômage
autrement dit qu il n'y a pas de
dimension anthropologique au problème
c'est à dire vous amener des gens de
notre anthropologie vous le maltraiter
économiquement et vous avez l'islamisme
et le terrorisme que ce que vous
donc c'est là où je suis j'habite pas le
même monde que lui je sais même pas
qu'on n'est pas d'accord c'est que je
comprends même pas qu'on peut penser
comme ça il ya un problème un trop beau
logique profonde on peut pas prendre des
gens qui viennent n'a pour tout le
mettre n'importe où et avec un tel
budget le transformer en trente ans
quelque chose et en question de rapport
à la famille nucléaire
il ya en question de rapport à la femme
il ya en question des rapports à l'autre
c'est à dire dans des républiques dans
des sociétés d cousant ou les gens ne
passent très peu de temps avec des
étrangers ou l'amitié et dans tout grave
parce que les gens sont vont jouer au
football avec leurs cousins comme on
peut comment on peut s'intégrer dans une
société où on fait tout on ma on s'est
marré avec des étrangers on appelle ça
des amis au demain on joue avec des
oranges ou avec des étrangers ont fait
on passe très peu de temps avec notre
avec notre famille s'apprend très très
longtemps dépassé d'une chose à l'autre
je recommande à tout le monde les livres
de de la grange sur les dénis de culture
il parle d ça il part des gens qui
arrivent de sahel et il explique à quel
point c'est compliqué même avec toute la
volonté l'argent du monde de dépasser
dans l'anthropologie à l'autre tout ça
pour nous pour macro n'existait pas donc
il fait fausse route
parce que le paradigme ne tient pas la
route mais parce que tout simplement
macron à une vision vous l'avez dit
totalement économique de la solution de
ce type de problème ils pensent que tout
simplement des mesures économiques une
relance une croissance un développement
économiques permettront de résoudre les
problèmes mais si les limites de
l'économisme la politique c'est aussi
vous
appelée de l'anthropologie cdu culturel
c'est de l'imaginaire ce sont aussi des
cordes qui sont parfois des codes
relation au spirituel qui font que à un
moment donné il faut se poser ce type de
questions mais est-ce qu'aujourd'hui les
hommes politiques sont armés pour
répondre à ce type de questions moi j'ai
pas le sentiment si vous voulez moi j'ai
quand même une perception de ces choses
c'est quand même une étrange défaite que
nous sommes en train de vivre ce déni de
réalité qui consiste à nier un moment
donné une forme de menace qui réel et
qui est en train de ronger une partie de
la société de la part des politiques et
de la part d'une grande partie de la
classe politique me relève du déni de
réalité c'est à peu près la même chose
dans les années 30 giron ne voyait pas à
monsieur hitler serait armé en
permanence mais on ne voulait pas le
voir ont dénoncé mais on ne voulait pas
le voir et il manuel macron est
exactement aujourd'hui comme d'autres
ont d'autres hommes politiques
dans cette enquête dans cette affaire me
n'est pas le seul suis d'accord avec
vous mais il est quand même dans cette
attitude ce qu'on est en train de porter
ses quand il y aussi une question de
l'intégration parce que ce que vous
venez de dire
il sait ça c'est un défaut d'intégration
alors pardon mais moi j'ai couvert
l'islam pendant plusieurs années pour
l'express donc il ya quelques temps de
cela les musulmans que j'ai vu ne
correspondent pas à ce que vous décrivez
là qu'est ce qui s'est passé il ya eu
effectivement une évolution mais les
musulmans sur lesquels j'ai travaillé
que j'ai interviewés étaient intégrés
dans la société française donc ça n'est
pas incompatible
on peut avoir une foi musulmane et
s'intégrer dans la société française
aujourd'hui on est arrivé à ce point du
débat où il semblerait que l'islam soit
totalement incompatibles salle est pas
vrai j'ai pu le vérifier non mais je
voudrais quand même le dire non mais je
pense que c'est important mais ni
difficulté je déroule la difficulté
d'aimer
non mais c'est pour ça que j'insiste
parce que il ya une religion il ya des
textes et puis après il ya ce qu'on en
fait c'est l'ailé ben oui mais ça c'est
important quand on est une fois ça
existe donc déjà ce premier point est
important deuxième point effectivement
c'est l'intégration et ce qui s'est
passé ces dernières années c'est qu'il
ya eu la montée d'effectivement d'un
islam qui était lui qu'on peut
considérer effectivement islamistes
salafistes et tous qui a pris
effectivement une énorme place là-dedans
qui a et qui a complètement fait évoluer
la question mais je veux dire nier le
fait qu'on puisse s'intégrer lorsqu'on
est musulman me semble juste quoiqu'il
paraît important c'est que la question
mais la question d'intégration jeu et le
problème c'est que le modèle républicain
c'est pas un modèle d'intégration
c'est le modèle assimilationniste c'est
qu'en fait la république à abandonner
maintenant depuis des décennies le
modèle assimilationniste est donc aussi
c'est une des raisons jolie du problème
auquel nous sommes confrontés sur
twitter à la question que l'on vous pose
et emmanuel macron at il raison de ne
pas vouloir interdire les listes
communautaire aux municipales vous êtes
65% à nous dire que non